hasura instantly turn your relational
database into a graphql or rest api
when building a full stack application
the end user likely needs to communicate
with a database
that means you need to build a secure
api in the middle so the client can tell
the server what it needs from the
database but building the perfect api
is easier said than done front-end
developers love using graphql but
back-end developers are faced with the
challenge of writing
efficient sql queries that resolve the
graphql schema the hasura engine
eliminates this problem
by automatically generating the schema
and resolvers for you
just point it to your postgres database
and it will use the existing tables and
views to generate an api that's ready to
roll in your frontend app if you don't
already have a database you can connect
one from anywhere in the cloud
then add tables and rows to it and
manage all of your data directly from
the web ui
and it can even help you configure
relationships between tables
in addition to databases you can also
connect third-party apis to your schema
to create a single source of truth for
all your data in some cases you may want
to extend the schema with your own
custom queries or mutations
actions provide a way to implement
custom business logic in an external
server or serverless function
to read and write data in more complex
ways in addition
you may want to trigger server-side code
when something changes in the database
like you may want to send a
transactional email when a new row is
added to a certain table hassura events
can be triggered based on operations to
a certain table
or scheduled with a cron job in the
background but one thing hysura doesn't
handle
is user authentication although you can
easily connect your favorite
authentication service and provide a
role session variable when the user
makes requests
which can then be used to implement
role-based access control with the click
of a button
now because the api is created with an
industry standard like graphql
you can use any graphql client that
you'd like to access the data on the
front end you might use something like
apollo
to query mutate and set up real-time
subscriptions to your database
in other words hasura is kind of like a
middleman that doesn't care what you use
on the front end or where you host your
actual database
and best of all it's an open source
project that can be self-hosted
or paid for as a fully managed service
with a free tier
this has been hasura in 100 seconds if
you want to see more short videos like
this
make sure to hit the like button and let
me know if you want to see a full
tutorial on this topic in the comments
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one